speaker Philip LeClaire from the Census
Bureau he was part of the design process
of top down which we heard about in the
previous talk and he'll tell us more
about in his talk and more broadly he'll
talk about Academia government and
Industry in the 2020 disclosure of voice
systems let's welcome Pila
thanks everybody so for folks who were
in the panel yesterday that introduction
I think already serves that's who I am
um I work for about the past five years
on the design of disclosure avoidance
system for the 2020 decennial census
um and today I've broken my talk up uh
into three parts so first I'm gonna give
kind of a primer on what TDA is describe
sort of some of the major components
going a little into a little bit more
detail than Alani did then I'm going to
move on to just two technical issues
that I thought were a particular
interest um and that I I particularly uh
that were also impressing and important
during the design of the system and
lastly I'll close with sort of some
thoughts on what I felt did and did not
work well about kind of the academic
government collaboration
um an industry's a bit in there as well
but it's really preferably emphasis on
academic government that was a part of
the core of the project
uh so first TDA is I mean it's just an
algorithm a randomized algorithm at a
high level of course it's a mechanism it
can be thought of as such
um it is the so there are several
formerly private algorithms under
development for use in the 2020
decennial census TDA is kind of the
first of those
um and it's used uh it's intended to be
used to produce the first two major data
product releases from the decennial
Census these are the pl-94-171
redistricting data area data summary
file um which you've already heard about
um and for the 2020 census has already
been released and then there is a
follow-up file that TDA is also intended
to help produce what tended to be the
algorithm that produces it the DHC or
demographic and housing characteristics
file DHD is kind of like PL but it has
less Geographic details so fewer of the
tabulations go down to the census Block
Level which is the the most granular
level of geography you'll find in the
census but it has more demographic
detail for non-geographic
characteristics
um so this slide is really most of us
are probably doesn't even necessarily
need to be said but as an algorithm TDA
has some major inputs that it takes uh
the two that I'll want to highlight here
that are really the primary ones are the
post edit slash data cleaning and
imputation Micro Data records which we
call the census edited file inside the
census uh the fact that this is after
edit an imputation and I'm actually very
helpfully Alani already pointed out but
that will be important in one of the
later slides uh so the census edited
file is what we write all of our
interpretations of the Privacy guarantee
with respect to
um the second set of key inputs here are
a set of structural zeros which are
really just relatively simple
descriptions of record types that are
considered to be logically impossible or
have been sort of determined during the
edit and data cleaning process to be so
implausible that if someone answered
then that they're probably uh they
probably just made a mistake
um and then a somewhat more involved set
of data dependent invariants
um this has caused no small number of
headaches during the design process at a
dependent invariance or are functions of
the sensitive data that would have been
different had we collected a different
sensitive data set and yet we are sort
of making the intentional uh decision to
not treat them in a formerly private way
and so these data dependent invariants
get no noise Infuse into them it's one
of the things that uh has complicated
the design process quite a bit then
there's processing I'm not going to talk
about that on this slide because we'll
talk about it more on the next slide and
it seems a bit redundant uh the end
product of that processing is a
synthetic microdata file essentially
called the microdata detail file this is
now where this is a Micro Data this is a
microdata level file that is privacy
protected in a formerly private fashion
although there are there are some
complications to that interpretation
that we'll get to in a little bit
for the most part uh top down operates
over schemas and takes counting queries
over them uh I don't really the details
of the schema are not super important
but I've given an example here I'm
really the primary thing to keep in mind
about this geography Cartesian product
with lgq Cartesian product Down The
Descent race so these are just an
individual variables that a person can
have reported data on in the census and
when you take the Cartesian product of
these you find that there are a lot more
possible record types in the country
than there are people in the country
which is kind of intuitively the the
fundamental tension within our desire to
publish high quality data on all of
these statistics and yet be able still
to provide a strong privacy guarantee
my list of requirements goes on I
probably could have gone on for several
more slides but uh these are the other
few I wanted to call out um so a little
bit more detail on the data dependent
and variants
um the second bullet was the one I guess
I want to highlight here so these are
actual examples of what things are held
in variant in the the TDA code
um so the state population totals are
held invariant
um there actually was some discussion uh
that this wasn't necessarily the only
way to discharge the Constitutional
requirements um for the way these
statistics are used but it seems the
simplest way and that we had plenty of
other things that were complicated to
deal with so just holding them directly
invariant especially at the state level
didn't seem terribly offensive then
slightly more complicated dependent
invariance holds on accounts of group
quarters facilities um group quarters
facilities are things like prisons
College dormitories military Barracks
that sort of thing
um these are uh well I'll touch on the
occupied part of this in a second but I
also want to mention the total housing
unit counts by block are also held in
variant importantly neither of these
second two invariants neither of these
two uh our Council of population
invariance but they do have implications
for the council populations that we can
publish so if there are no housing units
or in a particular area what this means
is TDA is not allowed to put people in
houses in that area
um if there are no reporters facilities
like no College dormitories then TDA
can't report that there are people in
college dormitories in that census block
um that upper bound can be a specialty
constraining and can significantly
filter the space of possible record
types that you can generate at the
census Block Level there is also in the
case of the reporters facilities is a
somewhat more annoying lower bound
there's a little bit more difficult to
reason about the Privacy implications of
um the lower bound on the group quarters
facilities is that there is no notion of
an empty group Porter's facility for
purposes of this product
um because of that if we know that there
are five College dormitories in an area
in a census block TDA is required to put
at least five people in college
dormitories in that census block
um so these are the kinds of invariants
to keep in mind as as whenever I
whenever I utter that phrase another
property we wanted to satisfy um was the
need to be able to get sort of uh
targeted accuracy or utility for
pre-specified tabulations this is sort
of a long time element of the design
process this is mostly motivated by the
database reconstruction theorem and just
sort of recognizing that in real world
databases where there are lots of
infrequent populations and counts it's
not realistic for us to be able to try
to get arbitrary accuracy for arbitrary
use cases without you know implicitly
releasing the entire database and having
sufficiently as many small counts in
there that there will be obvious glaring
privacy failures
uh then the elastic properties these are
probably mostly familiar to this
audience um so this one is I guess not
not always discussed but uh there was a
desire to be able to recover effectively
the true microdata as the budget gets
arbitrarily large
um and lastly um one that probably was
most important to alani's presentation
um inside the other stuff that was
discussed is transparency so um as Alani
mentioned we've released source code
previously uh we released the source
code for the production run of the of
the pl-94 uh redistricting product uh we
are currently I believe still expecting
to do that for the DHC production run
the code won't be exactly the same
um but we're expecting a same kind of
release process we've also released a
number of demonstration data products
run on the 2010 data um the idea here
being that mostly because of the
invariance and the requirement that we
generate microdata and we've ended up
with a fairly complicated way of
attempting to describe the error
distribution that's associated with the
with TDA um because it's not simple to
characterize one of the sort of most
straightforward ways to give people a
sense of the magnitudes and shapes of
air they might encounter was just to
provide an example Micro Data set that
we had generated from top down and of
course we also have been publishing the
parameters that we choose at production
settings
so in this slide you get a little bit
into a little bit more detail about how
top down works so Milani actually
covered some of this as well so I'll try
to move through it pretty quickly um we
take an overall privacy loss budget I'm
denoting it in row here because kind of
the operative framework for TDA uh the
operative privacy framework for the past
I think two and a half years or so has
been zero concentrated differential
privacy uh we split row up just using
simple sequential composition amongst a
list of geographic levels the list of
geographic levels isn't fixed it can
change depending on the data product
that we're handling but usually there
are six to eight of them I think in all
cases we then start by um the just the
kind of stuff I didn't write down here I
think it's an easier way to think about
it we start by taking uh counting query
measurements um using the discrete
gaussian mechanism uh so a distribution
with calcium shape but discrete uh
there's a very nice paper by uh I cannot
handle that provides an exactly for
sampling from this distribution we do
this at all of the geographic levels for
a pre-specified list of queries that we
want to try and get low error on we then
take these noisy measurements and then
the rest of the slide is really about
the post-processing we do to turn them
back into microdata the the very first
thing that we'll do is start at the
national level take the national level
on noisy measurements do a solve some
optimization problems convert them back
into something that can be interpreted
into microdata the second thing we'll do
is say okay now at the the sub-national
level we're going to sort of solve this
in a top-down fashion over a view over a
graphical tree but before we do that
there are a a Spate of off tree
geographies geographies that not will
not appear explicitly on the tree that
census will nevertheless publish
statistics about at the end of this
process to try to get better accuracy on
those off-spine geographies which isn't
super well controlled by just focusing
on the on-spine geographies a colleague
of mine Ryan Cummings I think about a
year and a half two years ago now
proposed that uh we could build a
heuristic to try to sort of alter the
structure automatically of the spine at
certain Geographic levels to pull some
of these off-spine geographies closer to
the on-spine geographies in the sense
that you attempt to minimize the number
of on-spine geographies you have to
combine add or subtract from one another
in order to get a Target offspine
geography and so this building of this
up in my spine is the next major step
that takes place given the optimized
spine we now have what we need in order
to sort of recurse down the rest of the
hierarchy the next step is usually going
to the state level using the state
budget to take we take the noisy
measurements I mentioned before at the
state level solve some optimization
problems to try to remain close to those
noisy measurements but now we have the
extra constraints these state level
histograms have to add up to the the
national level histogram that we
previously generated and then we just do
that over and over again until we get
down to the census Block Level the last
two bullet points are I guess easy to
run through really quickly and variants
are posed as constraints and all these
optimization problems so they're held
explicitly throughout this process and
then lastly we don't do this just once
we do this a bunch of times so first
there are two distinct universes persons
and units TDA is not responsible for
handling any queries that require
explicit joins
um like SQL style joins between those
two universes to compute um so we handle
these two universes for the most part
completely separately we also handle the
these two mutually exclusive sort of
priority known to be mutually exclusive
populations in the US and Puerto Rico
completely separately and then lastly
and this one actually is not independent
despite what I may have written here um
we do this for each of two products bl94
DHC um the reason these aren't
independent is that one of the design
choices we were asked to respect is that
when you sum over the tabulation or some
over the microdata in DHC appropriately
you should get back the corresponding
pl-94 tabulations and microdata
so this is kind of a high level picture
we're just running down a tree
generating microdata as we go
I've got two slides that dig into the
the sort of a little bit more of the
mathematical detail although with some
things kind of hidden
um the overarching picture here is that
we really probably want to solve some
sort of intractable mixed integer
quadratic program
um that enables us to get very close to
the the statistics that we've taken
noisy measurements on um but generate
something that can be interpreted as
microdata uh we sort of knew from the
beginning that that wasn't going to
happen um it was unlikely we were going
to come up with a method for that in
time
um so what we did was build this this
heuristic that splits that into two sub
problems non-negatively squares problem
and then an integer rounding problem
this is the non-negatively squares
problem
um it's got a summation out here that
zooms over Alphas in the set C of gamma
the alphas are child geographies of
apparent Geographic unit gamma um so C
of gamma is just children of gamma there
is then a workload Matrix W that's what
the W here stands for each row in the
workload Matrix can be interpreted as
sort of corresponding to a vector that
denotes the particular Target counting
query or tabulation that we want to get
low error on uh we'll sum over both of
those our optimization variable is this
h-star sub Alpha which is just a
vectorized representation of all the
possible record types from the schema we
looked at before that could correspond
to this product and we're going to try
and choose that HSR sub Alpha to make
its Vector product with the appropriate
workload row
um the difference between that and the
appropriate noisy measurement the noisy
measurement for this child uh small N2
Norm uh then there are a bunch of
constraints most of them are completely
straightforward so it's a non-negatively
squares problem so we have a
non-negativity constraint I'm kind of
cheating on the second one really this
is this is just saying that H starts at
Alpha has to live in the space of
possible microdata sets that are
consistent with the invariants um
technically I should have an alpha
commas f as one of the functions of this
this invariant constraint
um yeah I can ask you later but just
while it's up I wanted to ask if you
thought about other uh other Norms than
L2
uh so we didn't try anything other than
L2 and L1 in this particular setup we
had a lot of discussion about completely
different ways of trying to approach the
problem but this was the only one that I
ever really got close to the point where
we thought it was implementable okay so
it was an Implement implementability
decision yeah for the most part thanks
um and so moving on I guess to the
second to last constraint so this is
just uh the the geographic consistency
constraints saying some of the children
you should get back the histogram that
corresponds to the parents and then
lastly just the domains these things
live in so the reels were really
technically the the floats um 64s I
think in this case and there are a few
notes about feasibility and other
properties um that the solutions of this
kind of problem have in our particular
case
if I end the last note about DHC and the
consistency constraint with PL which is
not pictured in the set of constraints
and also technically there is a slightly
different and easier version of the
optimization problem where you don't
have the geographic consistency
constraint when you're solving that
first national level problem
most of what I'll actually say in the
next 10-fold slides is about the second
problem so we have this non-negative
floating Point valued output estimate of
a histogram that comes from the
non-negatively Spurs problem we'd like
to get that into a form where it
corresponds to non-negative integers
that still satisfy the constraints this
is the problem we solve to try and get
to that point
um it should look really similar I mean
the structure is nearly identical to the
problem we looked at in the last slide
that was the non-negatively squares
problem one notable change is the the W
is now a w Prime uh the the issue here
is just that integer programming in
general is more difficult than
continuous optimization and so we need
additional conditions on the structure
of this Matrix concatenated with the
structure of the Matrix representing the
constraints in order to make sure that
the resulting problem is tractable so we
have a different Matrix as the workload
Matrix the other major change is that
our optimization variable is now this
each positive sub Alpha which is a
binary Vector it's no longer a vector
over sort of arbitrary uh reels and this
is important because it's now a rounding
problem we're asking for each of the
entries and the non-negatively squares
problem that we estimated the solution
for should we push that to the next
integer or to the lead integer
immediately below it and the information
we're going to use to do that is the
fractional part of that histogram that
we previously estimated H Starks of
alpha minus the four of H star sub Alpha
we're going to take the vector product
of that fractional part with the the
query that we're currently trying to get
low error on and then we're going to try
and force that to be close to what we
would get if we took the corresponding
product but with this optimization
variable that's a binary Vector the
primary the rest of the constraints are
all just sort of like you taught us
newtonous these these correspond to what
you saw in the last problem but sort of
switch to work with the fractional
representation except in places where I
feed it again with kind of like the H
positives of alpha lives in the
invariant set thing here a similar thing
is going on there and the primary
property that we we ended up combing in
on here to try to make destructible was
totally into modularity I'm skipping
over that a little bit because we're
going to talk about it more in a few
slides and it would be boring to talk
about it now before we get to that
here's a list of just sort of advantages
and disadvantages to the use of TDI okay
A little bit of this is somewhat
repetitive so I'm going to kind of pick
out the ones I think are most
interesting
um so TDA is complicated Alani pointed
this out before it has fairly complex
structure to it this this makes it
difficult to reason about the error
distributions in a way that's nice we
definitely can't give you a closed form
description for them and we also at
least currently don't have a nice
numerical way to estimate them for you
in a public-facing way although we
discussed doing that pretty extensively
it does also have some other nice perks
I mean so an obvious thing it has it has
kind of Base validity for the end user
particularly for non-sophisticated users
who aren't going to want to do any kind
of statistical inference it's convenient
for them to have access to something
that kind of looks familiar to the data
they've used in the past for internal
systems it was also important that we
regenerate microdata as the final
product so that it could slot into the
existing production Pipeline and not
cause massive disruptions to the way
systems had to expect in ingest this
data it also has some useful accuracy
properties so this bullet point here in
particular TDA is really good at finding
zeros in small cells which is incredibly
important given that we know
um because there are so many more
tabulations in that schema that we
talked about before than uh than there
are people in the United States
um we know that most of those are going
to be true zeros so it's important that
we be able to find most of them
correctly uh and just a quick
calculation there are a lot of ways to
illustrate this but one we've been
looking at recently is that if we take a
recent version of the demonstration data
products that we published which are not
quite finalized in terms of budget but
are close to it and we look at all of
the zeros there and we compare them to
the zeros in the original uh 2010 sf1
tabulations sf1 was a little bit of of
of grift here a little bit of of
inaccuracy here but for the most part
you can think of sf1 as the predecessor
product of DHC so DHC is taking a subset
of tabulations from sf1
um and and is sort of the new name in
some sense for most of the sf1
tabulations but basically they agree on
on 90 or so of the zero of the cells
that are zero and so if you believe
sorry are you I just want to be sure and
understand are you saying that there are
about the same number of zeros or are
you saying that zero means zero
zero means zero do you mean zero means
zero in like the underlying and apparent
zero is a real zero no
there are other
there are other comparisons we
've convinced ourselves that we're
actually hitting true zeros most of the
time I don't have any statistics on that
up here this is just saying when we
compare it to the swapping algorithm
that if you believe that it was mostly
getting zeros correct then then you
probably should believe that this is
also getting mostly true zeros um it's a
little bit of a a an indirect out of
getting at it and I probably would have
preferred to have a statistic that looks
directly at this f um but I didn't bring
one today
um and then lastly there's this last
comment is just uh sort of repeating
things I've already said about the the
complex sort of data dependent error
distribution
okay um that's kind of the the extent to
which I wanted to go into detail about
what top-down is as an algorithm I'm
going to jump now into two specific
technical issues that have been
important to the project and that I also
think are fun to talk about
uh so the first of these is talking
about how invariance led us to Total
universities the property you wanted to
focus on
um this actually maybe will be a little
bit more familiar to this audience than
it I think was to the folks inside the
bureau because I feel like there's more
of an operations background here
um and just create optimization
background where you actually run into
total unit modularity most of the folks
inside the bureau it's not something
that they would have had to handle with
before this project
um but so this is kind of the narrative
as I imagine it um in variance uh in the
very beginning of the project the second
bullet point um there were a bunch of
Statistics that people felt were given
this large change to differential
privacy that people felt were
sufficiently important that they didn't
want to infuse noise into them which is
kind of uh it is sort of a p d wave PDP
way of thinking about these things um
but there was a very strong desire for
this unfortunately at the beginning of
the project we also didn't really have
much of a notion of what the impacts of
this would be
um some of us have done some mixed
energy linear programming in the past um
or had other discrete optimization
elements in our background and so we
kind of had a sense that well if we let
them just throw constraints at us
arbitrarily eventually we're going to
run into NP hard problems or worse and
we don't want that to happen
um we also didn't really understand at
the time what the Privacy implications
of it were we knew we were stepping
specifically and actively away from a
formal privacy framework and not
infusing noise into these the subset of
Statistics but it wasn't necessarily
clear what interpretable guarantee we
would retain at the end
um and so this first set of slides in
this in this sub second part of the talk
isn't going to address that second issue
but the first issue the computational
remember keeping things computationally
tractable we basically needed a
framework for thinking about when
management came to us and said hey we
want to throw this new constraint in is
that okay
um and so that's where we're going to
move next
I can't tell me when you have had like
the mic right up to your mouth okay so
if you do just Jump Right In
um so what is total unit modularity mean
for folks who aren't familiar with it in
the audience it's a property of matrices
so a matrix a is said to be totally
unimodular if for every square
sub-matrix of it you get determinants
that are in negative one zero and one
it's important because of this this
really well known theorem or at least
sort of well-known theorem I guess
depending on the group but this
important theorem um from the discrete
optimization literature uh that shows
that any non-empty polyhedron
corresponding to a ton Matrix when
paired with a right-hand side Vector
that is integer valued and interpreted
as the feasible region of an
optimization problem you have this uh
this nice this nice interpreter this
nice theorem that says that all the
corner points all the extreme points of
that polyhedron are integer valued and
further um from sort of basic linear
programming theory you know at least one
of those pointer points is going to be
optimal and we have nice uh algorithmic
techniques interior Point methods with
crossover I mean in some settings
Simplex methods that can find that
optimal Corner point attractively so
this was kind of our oh well okay if we
can get this property or something like
it um then maybe we're okay
foreign
ly we run into a pretty um simple to
describe problem pretty immediately um
the integer program solved by the vast
isn't totally unimodular and it's not
totally even a modular for this very
basic reason
um that when you take a non-linear
program modeling an minimization of an
absolute value uh or anything in the in
the one Norm
um you end up with a linear program it
looks something like this and at Large
Scale it's just kind of like this but
fancier unfortunately this kind of
linear program doesn't have a constraint
Matrix that is that is totally even a
modular because you immediately end up
with determining sub with
subdeterminants that are that are
negative two I'm not negative one zero
or one
questions
what what's pen oh it just stands for
penalty a penalty variable uh probably
could come with 100 names um maybe I was
thinking about writing at the time
so uh we had this problem we wanted
totally Union modularity but we didn't
have it we wanted to be able to still
get totally modularity like things uh we
were fortunately able to show
um the I think this is actually still
only written down in internal documents
unfortunately but we were able to show
that if you delete at least one if you
delete one of each of the pair of
absolute value constraints and you get
kind of this really reduced linear
program that removes sort of the obvious
things that are breaking and causing us
to violate tum
um that you still have the time like
property you still have kind of this
integral extreme Point property as long
as this um this sort of sub Matrix can
be shown to be totally unimodular but
that's enough to sort of drag out a
tum-like property or an integral extreme
point-like property
um and then still sort of get the
tractability you need for finding uh
integer valued Solutions
uh we then have to figure out okay well
what kinds of conditions do we need on
the query space we're working over in
order to make sure that we have this
relaxed tunnel-like property uh so what
we ended up with was this
um if we have no more than two tuples of
nested queries uh then we have Tom on
this reduced sort of sub Matrix and
that's sufficient to kind of get us
where everyone want to be uh by nested I
just mean this is kind of made up
language internally um but a really
simple example of an acid query is
sunrise by voting age nests within send
race
um and all I mean here is that if you
marginalize over the voting age
Dimension you will get exactly the sun
race query um so one query can sort of
be reduced to the other query by
submission uh this was nice because it
put us in a place where we could now you
know actually give reasonable answers to
management when they ask us
um well can we impose this extra set of
constraints will this break everything
computationally will we not be able to
run anything for the 2020 census
um so uh certain examples we could
easily say yes structural zeros which
are basically reduced to univariate
constraints that amount to just removing
variables from a problem so they can
never violate total unit modularity they
can never take you from a ton Matrix to
a non-tum matrix um so they were
completely okay uh on the other hand
other constraints that we really would
have liked to be able to impose on the
optimization problems couldn't be
accommodated probably one of the best
examples of this is that it would be
nice if we could solve the over the
person if it gets all over the the units
problem
um and impose the extra constraint that
when we sum over households of different
sizes you end up getting back the same
population that you've got on the
person's problem unfortunately this
requires coefficients like a seven on
populations or on households of size
seven the count of households of size
seven and the trivial sub-matrix
corresponding to just that one
coefficient clearly doesn't have a
determinant in one in zero one or
negative one so we immediately have to
say Okay well we'd like that but
unfortunately we can't do this
um one other thing I want to point out
here which actually was a little bit
deflating when we found it because it
meant this wasn't entirely novel work um
but we're still also kind of encouraging
um Ryan Cummings actually the fellow I
mentioned before who built the the
heuristic for spine optimization
um he discovered after we had done this
that there's actually some pre-existing
literature uh that that uh so in
particular this first paper I think
actually implies our results um as a
special case and so this is a bit of a
bummer because it means the results not
entirely up but not entirely novel but
it's also encouraging because we're
using this in a production context and
it would be nice to know that someone
else has derived the same results that
we kind of reduce a little bit of the
worry about having made a mathematical
mistake
probably going to cover this but did you
look Beyond totally your new modularity
for integrality
um so the other the other routes we had
discussed early on and honestly I'm not
sure I could even list the other
algorithms that were approach to us I
think message passing algorithms had
come up quite a bit um like more
polyhedral properties like no not really
neurality no no no we didn't
um but I'd love to talk with you after
if you have any other suggestions or
properties that we might be able to use
in the future um ideally that would
relax it a bit that's just a very smart
fraction of integer integral politics
yeah yeah I would I would love to have
extra suggestions that we can hunt down
in the future that would be great
thank you
um so moving on to the second sort of
technical subtopic uh this is moving
away a bit from from Tom
um now what we're going to focus on uh
is ways in which the invariance um the
size of the budget that we've expended
the Privacy lost budget
um and also just like the nature of the
Privacy guarantee the ways in which
those have a complicated
um are and forced us to consider
relaxations and complications to the way
that we try to reason about the Privacy
grantee
um so uh these first two things I think
are relatively clear already the third
thing is maybe less clear these are uh
the production budgets uh for the pl 94
run PL 94171 run um 2.56 in the person's
Universe 0.07 in the units universe and
the DHC product these are not um
absolutely finalized yet but these are
kind of the candidate budgets for the
production run row of 496 and 770
um for folks accustomed to thinking
about Epsilon this may not be
immediately intuitive but
um I will say I don't think if you asked
anyone in the literature about these
figures that except for maybe the row
equals 0.07 that they would be very
happy with us
uh I also it's not just sort of how I
anticipate folks reacting in the
literatures it's not really the primary
way that I think about if these are if
these are large or small
um uh we have sort of struggled to find
nice ways of communicating these to both
Technical and non-technical decision
makers in a way that makes accessible
and intuitive whether these values are
are large or small
um and so this is the primary way that I
think we've sort of very tentatively
settled on
um is uh taking a common interpretation
of literature in terms of type 1 and
type 2 error bounds on hypothesis tests
um and using that as the interpretation
that we want to run with
um that there are some some ways you
can't do this because of the invariance
on certain kinds of uh neighboring
databases so we we can't look at bounds
and hypothesis tests that would take a
record for a person and move them from
one state to another we'd like to be
able to say things about that but um
that that would end up violating the
state level population invariance and so
with hypothesis test bounds there would
be kind of meaningless that being said I
think it's still informative
um mostly because it's negative to look
at what the overall on this what the
overall bounds on power are and so in
this table I've taken the three columns
here are the three major products the
first major product PL and the other two
products I've broken down by Universe
H's units or housing um and P is persons
um and so really the primary thing to
focus on here is this last this last
column this is something over the
budgets for all of the individual
products and looking at the grand total
budget the top right cell in the table
this 0.99 is the worst case power bound
corresponding to sort of an arbitrary uh
bounded universes I.E changing a record
to another record bound four hypothesis
tests so they fixed significance level
of 0.01 this is not good we don't want
0.99 it is bad if it's close to one
um the lower bound on it is if it is
point zero one it can't get lower than
that and so
when I say that these row expenditures
are large in the worst case considering
the grand total budget this is what I
mean even when we have a fixed
significance level of 0.01 we're already
very very close to the 1.0 upper bound
and then when we communicated this to
dsep when they've been reasoning about
their choices of budget um to try and
make clear exactly sort of you know how
not great the the worst case bound is
for the overall uh kinds of grand total
budget guarantees that are most commonly
discussed in the literature
now there's one other sub point this is
maybe more just than me indulging myself
because I think it's an important topic
that comes up frequently
um there is also
um another complication in trying to
handle how we can describe these things
to policy makers um is not just the
invariance not just the size of the
budget but also that it's kind of
fundamentally complicated to ask people
to think about what privacy means and I
don't mean this in kind of like an
abstract sense I mean in the very sense
that the literature usually one of the
ways in which the literature probably
the dominant way in which the TP
literature has usually tried to ask
people think about this
um one of the earliest references that
I'm aware of that tries to give kind of
an intuition for this is Frank
mcsherry's blog post where he talks
about secrets about you and your secrets
um internally I have come after talking
about this a lot heavily um with Dan
Kiefer and of a bunch of other members
of our team if you think about this
instead in the language generalizable
inference versus privacy violating
inference
um the idea here just goes back to um
for folks who maybe attended the panel
yesterday
um it's important to be able to separate
inferences that are about individuals
but are are only about individuals
because there's no way to have a large
scale pattern without enabling inference
about a lot of individuals to separate
those from inferences about individuals
that are clearly using the information
that uniquely belongs to them and that's
kind of what this is sort of attempting
to get at and what I take the the usual
comparison of two worlds to also be
trying to get at we're sort of
attempting to causally isolate what
inferences are what are the inferences
that your data's presence in the
database are enabling to be made that
information is sort of fundamentally
yours in a way that is very difficult to
argue otherwise whereas inferences that
can be made about you even if your data
wasn't in the database so arguably maybe
isn't your information even though it's
about you
um that that concept is important but
subtle and particularly when you're
talking with people who haven't spent a
lot of time in a lot of time in the TP
literature it's really difficult to get
that across so our solution which
doesn't really address this last problem
um although I think the type one two
particular stuff has worked better than
looking at the Bayesian sort of way of
framing the same kind of idea our
solution to this is to to focus it's
only a partial solution I should say
that obviously can't make one equal to
two
um our solution to this is to look at
partial versions of the budget and at
more limited counter factual comparisons
so instead of talking about worlds that
differ in your entire record we will
talk about worlds that differ just in a
subset of bits of your record uh this
essentially requires no new math which
is certainly convenient and it also
gives you guarantees uh that are
precisely stainable uh but come with
sort of meaningfulness maybe the wrong
word but they come with quantitative
bounds that are not close to that 1.0
upper bound
um and so this is probably the most
promising example of those this is the
the block and block group guarantee is
how we refer to this this is just taking
all of the queries that were expanded at
the Block Level
um that sort of have non-zero
sensitivity with respect to a change of
a person's record from one block to
another
um within their block group
um and you can see quantitatively this
is much more likely she would have hoped
I hope anyway that that first attack
table would have looked like the 0.01
significance level we're not quite down
at there in the top right cell but we're
pretty close point zero four is not that
much larger than point zero one I I I
think this is actually quite strong
quantitatively speaking
um there's also I should say is focus on
this particular per attribute guarantee
is specifically motivated by uh well a
the fact that the overall budget is very
large and that getting buy into a much
smaller Global budget seemed unlikely to
happen
um but also by the fact that we had
conducted the Reconstruction
redundification attack that Alani talked
about and we knew that for that attack
one of the major variables that were key
to making it work was being able to
discern this sort of very granular
Geographic detail uh blocks are
something like a third by a third mile
on average
um although they could be quite
irregular in shape
foreign
a few other examples here um not very
many more but one other example of upper
attribute power bound
um is for all queries that uh have
non-zero sensitivity with respect to
whether or not a person's record
indicated that they were in a same-sex
relationship in this case with the
householder because of the way the data
is structured and I picked this one
because I thought you know it might be
something that people would be concerned
about and I think the important thing is
to pull away here are we're not close to
the 1.0 upper Bound in the top right
cell but we're also really far from the
point zero one lower bound
so do I have a shirt so you're asking if
we altered about a record only whether
there is a same-sex relationship with
the householder yes
um I also want to want to clarify that
so there may be an argument for actually
increasing these a bit because this this
is only based on queries that directly
uh modify the variable corresponding to
that person whether they have a reported
response saying they were in a same-sex
relationship with the householder
arguably
um there was also information embedded
about this in the sex information of
both of the parties and their individual
personal records that's not reflected in
this table and I actually think I would
like to do an updated version of it that
adds that to it
um but hopefully that answers the
question yeah I'll ask you more later
thanks sure uh and so the primary point
I just have here is that this is not
nearly as as sort of dispiriting
quantitatively as the table we saw for
the overall Global budget um but it's
also nowhere near the the much Rosier
picture we saw with the block and block
group guarantee
um and I don't actually know what to
tell you to take away from that at the
end of this process I'm more interested
in the community of people who have
studied the the difference of privacy
and then the DP communities sort of take
on this
um I don't think the census is kind of
unique in ending up with a grand total
budget that's that's quite large by sort
of conventional academic standards
um I also it's also sort of clear that
there's not like there isn't a hey this
is the budget everyone should use it is
there is some subjectivity in it you
have to sort of compare the accuracy
costs uh to the privacy considerations
um and so at best you might come up with
a procedure that people could follow in
order to try to come up with a Justified
choice of privacy lost budget but I
guess what I wonder is whether or not
guarantees like this are of interest
um to the community at all or or if the
only real answer is no the global budget
has to be made smaller and arguments
need to be made about that I will also
on knowledge because I think it's
important um because these are not these
are this is a relatively unusual way of
trying to frame discussion about the
Privacy guarantee they come with
precisely stable bounds
um that have meaningful sort of human
readable statements associated with them
but they are not worse case in the same
way you would usually think of DP bounds
as being worst case and in particular
they're not worst case because increased
knowledge of dependence between
variables within the person's record are
obviously the kind that if that
dependence is increasing that should
make you more skeptical skeptical about
this kind of Purity
um if my knowing about all of the other
variables in your record other than your
block is going to help me figure out
which block you're in in your block
group then it hardly matters uh that we
we have sort of uh focused on that block
through the block only guarantee
okay those are the two uh sort of
technical subtopics I wanted to jump
into
um and then I'm going to close with some
thoughts on academic uh government
industry collaboration this is not an
attempt to sort of outline how you
should go about this because I don't
think I'm an expert on that
um but it is an attempt to I guess
reflect a bit on the past five years and
sort of things that I think I have seen
work well and work poorly um mostly
focusing on the things that I think have
worked well
um as I mentioned before I'll probably
mostly talk about the academic and
government side of things I have
admissions going to skip most of this
slide I have a list here of projects I
know are ongoing mostly formerly private
projects this is not even remotely
exhaustive and is very very heavily
skewed towards government projects
because of the ones that I naturally end
up hearing about maybe the one that I
would like to highlight at the end here
um is that there is a program of census
Cooperative agreements um that are
sometimes used to try and engage
external researchers and sort of guide
them towards topics that are of special
interest to census and so we have uh one
maybe two but at least one of those
ongoing right now I'm focused on complex
sampling survey designs and trying to
focus on issues in them that are are not
really addressed in the literature right
now
questions
on academic do you need to be a U.S
national to be able to work on these
projects
like but no I understand the question
yeah I was just pausing for uh to check
out my thoughts for a second
um so
I would want to be absolutely certain
but I believe that is the answer is no
for this this sort of census Cooperative
agreement issue I don't think you have a
there's any requirement for you to be a
U.S citizen
um I can tell you absolutely absolute
certainty that is not the case for these
kind of contractors
um the Contracting groups that are
working on census products uh so
um the the those restrictions don't
apply here they do apply if you want
some work internally at census as a
full-time federal employee they're the
citizens requirement applies but I'm
also happy to talk about it after too
and put you in touch with so I am not in
management at census I sort of serve as
a quasi manager sometimes on this
project but um there are probably better
people than me to talk about to make
sure that you're getting exactly the
right answers there
okay and then to jump into I guess I've
got like 10 to 15 minutes here I'll try
to leave a little bit of time for your
questions comments just sort of
generally yelling
um but I'm gonna go through a few more
specific examples of things I thought
worked well uh in this sort of
collaborative effort
um so the first and this won't be
available to everyone obviously but uh
Dan Kiefer who was at the time the
scientific lead in the project sort of
still is spiritually the scientific lead
but we don't have as much of his time
now
um so he doesn't serve quite in the same
capacity anymore uh he was able to take
a one year sabbatical at the start of
the project this was really helpful um
for a lot of reasons that are difficult
to write down um personally but there's
basically tons of tacit knowledge that
goes into running both an agency and a
large survey or census project and
you're just not going to find most of
that written down anywhere
um it's helpful even just for simple
things like figuring out what kinds of
implicit assumptions are people bringing
to the table when they come to ask you
questions or make complaints
um how quickly are you likely to get
access to data that you need in order to
make some part of the project work uh
what sorts of computational restrictions
and considerations are there how quickly
can we get new soft software if we think
we need it that kind of thing all of
this stuff you won't find written down
in any nice publicly reusable place so
it was really helpful to have I'm Dan on
site basically as a census employee for
that first year
this next bullet point isn't actually
something I usually touch on because I
don't really feel like I have the same
perspective leadership has
um but I think it is important given
that the point of this talk uh so Johnny
about who's who came up in Melania
slides Victoria velkov who is the
director for demographic programs uh
alfontano the associate director of
potential census programs um and Ron
Jarman who's the deputy director and Ron
also sits at the the head of data
stewardship executive policy committee
which is the committee that makes sort
of the final privacy lost budgeting
decisions
um these four folks um from my point of
view seem to be committed and convinced
fairly early on in the project that
there was a strong need for privacy
modernization and I bring this up
because
we've been yelled at quite a lot
um and critiqued quite a lot over the
choices we made in this project and some
of the costs that come with them I can
imagine pretty easily in alternative
history where they come maybe to 2018 in
the middle of it and just say look this
isn't worth it this is this is really
really painful to deal with we're
catching flock from all sides no one
really seems especially happy let's just
fall back to the old swapping system
um I think this would have been
unfortunate for because it could only
really have gone one of two ways in my
mind
um one uh way it could have gone is that
we just use swapping sort of at
parameter settings that were
historically common and that sort of
operate in a light touch da regime I I
don't think that would have been
reasonable it would have been sort of
kicking the can down the road and
waiting for someone to host an even
larger Recon Reid attack that's more
sophisticated to yell at us in the
future about not having made that
decision correctly the alternative is we
could have used the swapping system and
just like Jack the parameters way up we
could have swapped like at a 90 rate or
something ridiculous
um I think this would have probably
given some reasonable privacy guarantees
it still wouldn't have been perfect
because it can't change sampling zeros
in the same way that DP can
um but it would also have had uh the
side effect that swapping is essentially
a local sort of model algorithm it's
operating record by record before you do
aggregation so you should have a
fundamental significant loss of
statistical efficiency going on there
and I think that would have been very
unfortunate
moving on to still other things that I
thought were important to making the
project get to a point where we're sort
of reasonably happy with it
um was our sort of lack of ambition I
guess to put it a little strangely
um so as a good example of this one of
the things that we never anticipated
trying to even deal with was imputation
and Alani touched on this and I also
touched on this one of the earlier
slides as well as data cleaning and
editing these processes
especially imputation there's a clear
example there so I think Chris Clifton's
group in the DP Community get started to
look at this a bit um and they basically
pointed out that the hot tech imputation
systems that are used commonly at census
don't offer any guarantee uh or any
natural bound on the global sensitivity
um they might just use a record a whole
bunch of times it's maybe unlikely maybe
there's some clever thing you can do to
reason about that but at least the
simple ways of using about global
sensitivity weren't going to work there
um so we didn't want to deal with that
given that we had plenty of other
complicated problems to try and solve
and we wanted to be able to get this
project to a point where where it was
reasonably uh complete but I think it's
important that even though we we sort of
outlined these things as tasks we
weren't going to try and Tackle yet we
still retain the ability to make precise
guarantees precisely stateable formal
guarantees with respect to the census
edited file the post-edited imputation
data I think that's important because it
basically says look this stuff has a
nice formal privacy guarantee associated
with it this last major stage of
processing but this stuff before it is
sort of informal so it's leaving and
living in PDP kind of Legacy land and
making that distinction isn't important
in a real world project because it
allows you to kind of work piecemeal but
still report to people that you've made
a significant strides in improving the
way the system works and can be
described from the point of view of its
privacy guarantee
a similar issue but I won't talk much
about it because I've already talked a
lot about it is invariance we had to had
to bound them pretty early on with the
sort of the way of reasoning about what
we're and we're not okay and then
another example and this gets into the
work that Tamal is doing uh labs and
miter Corporation they are helping on
this group two products that didn't
exist at the start of the project uh but
those of us working on what has TDA now
manages pointed out early on that a lot
of the a significant minority of the
tabulations present in the the DHC
product or at the time in what would
have been the DHC product and also in
sf2 and other follow-on products
um we're expensive in the sense that
they might have arbitrarily High Global
sensitivity and it didn't seem like
there was any obvious way to address
that so we would need to have very
different conversations about how to try
and address that and probably come up
with with quite different algorithms for
managing them so these were spun off
into their own separate product to be
managed and now it has taken on a life
of its own and is being managed
separately
on the last example of this that I'll
touch on is quality assurance because I
think this is kind of weird and
interesting and I don't have any idea
really what to do about it long term
um but it's also the most recent of
these these struggles that has kind of
come up uh so originally and this is
this is me casting back like maybe four
or five years ago imagining discussions
of leadership um on the the team for
developing TDA originally our our
conception of the way interaction would
go with the census edited file the
confidential data um after TDA had run
was really simple and idealized and I
guess looking back kind of naive um we
kind of imagined that people just would
never really touch it once we'd run the
algorithm they would just unless they
had another product to produce and the
compelling reason for it in a DP
algorithm associated with it they would
just kind of never look at that data
once they'd run TDA and then they would
just be kind of this inviolent firewall
between the two unfortunately there are
a lot of reasons this doesn't really
work out very well in practice
um first and probably most importantly a
historical QA process processes just
don't work like that or at least they
haven't that census um historically away
processes involve people manually who
are very familiar with the data looking
at the sensitive data looking at the
final post privatized data and hunting
for what I can only describe kind of
vaguely as problems
um we have had I think probably
harder discussions about what should
constitute a problem since adopting DP
um but before I get into that that
discussion I guess there's also a second
reason that this this kind of seems sort
of Impractical which is that even if we
were not to allow the folks doing the
quality assurance checking to look at
the underlying confidential data those
people are often the same people who
cleaned it out in the first place who
handled the amputation systems who uh
sort of did everything since it got to
the central curator in the first place
sort of like you know mind wiping
devices being invented you can't ask
them to just throw away that information
they're going to probably be thinking
about it when they're looking at the
final data and trying to figure out is
this okay so so given this kind of
situation we ended up at compromises
maybe the wrong word here um something
of a compromise we just said okay look
QA is going to be conducted in this
historical way you're going to compare
directly to the sensitive microdata but
then we kind of want to give this
somewhat vague prohibition we really
really really really really don't want
you to misuse that power to cheat and
like re-roll the dice on the system
until the distribution looks nice to you
because that defeat would defeat the
entire purpose of this it's also
especially hard to do in tda's case
because at least the current version of
the algorithm on DHC takes something
like a week to run so if you only get so
many dice rules even if you do
aggressively cheat but we still don't
want you to do that we'd like to set a
good precedent for other products and
try to at least in spirit treat this
separation the way it should be treated
and and not use the confidential data to
make final sort of editing decisions on
the post-privatized data but this does
leave an interesting question which is I
mean they're still they are going to
make these direct comparisons
um there is kind of an understanding
that the Privacy side of the group would
very much like to limit any changes we
make based on that to things that are
bugs and can be like
unambiguously identified as programming
errors
um but if they were to just find a large
perturbation that's not evidence of the
bug then just happen to be a very low
probability event in the discrete
gaussian mechanism it's interesting to
ask like what would we do with that and
I can't answer that question that
ultimately would probably be kicked up
to the data stewardship executive policy
committee they would argue about it and
they would have a hard decision to make
they could potentially say we want to
re-roll the dice this is not acceptable
um and I I
don't really know what note to end on
with this sled I guess because I don't
know what direction this should go in
the future but I guess I'll say it
reminds me of the exploratory versus uh
confirmatory data analysis distinction
I've actually in this room I think four
years ago a visiting social scientist
asked what can we do to make traditional
exploratory data analysis practices
still work and I think the answer was
basically you can't stop doing them
um which it puts us I think in a very
similar situation as here uh because QA
kind of is basically operating like
exploratory data analysis there's not
like a nice pre-written algorithm for
how they're exploring the data they're
just kind of looking for stuff that
looks wrong and going from there
foreign
so this is like a meta point that I have
that I have thought about in terms of
like exploratory analysis and negative
supplies here is like it's like really
when we're talking about something at
the scale of like you know census Micro
Data they're not just like looking at
the data and they're not like you know
scrolling through but rather there's
some
maybe there's some set of like like
analyzes that they like most commonly do
the captures some large fraction of
their like checking if they're like you
know checking marginals or like you know
things like this because I think when we
talk about data being being of this
scale no one is like literally like
looking at the data but they're doing
some set of like simple analyzes of the
data and maybe there's there's an
opportunity to like privatize those and
of course it won't be everything but it
might be the majority of things and then
there's a few other like you know
bespoke analyzes they might do but like
do you think that is
reasonable in this case or not
I it's actually exactly the kind of sort
of sort of training that I've had in in
the moments where I've tried to figure
out what this might look like long term
I think it has to move in stages and so
it's good to it's very very good I think
to think of it as let's try and hit the
bulk of these things maybe get agreement
that those can be made DP for QA
purposes but then you can still have
like some bespoke analyzes as long as
you make that group sort of
qualitatively in some sense smaller
maybe that's better
um I think one of the major challenges
here is just that
in the 2020 project specifically we're
already causing a massive disruption to
the way census Works in order to install
DP in as the da system to simultaneously
have asked them hey well we also don't
want you to do QA that way here's
another DP system that's going to sit in
between you and the way QA Works what I
think have been a deeply difficult cell
but maybe 10 years down the line maybe
for 20 30 20 40 as hopefully DP becomes
increasingly accepted
and and maybe the distinction between
top down and a very very simple sort of
interface for their QA can be kind of
separated from one another and then we
can move QA of the QA DP algorithm to a
space that is a bit simpler this is a
very long rambling way of saying yes I
think I think that's a great idea and
that's kind of where I hope things move
in the future but it depends on like
incremental gaining of stakeholder
support in order to make sure that it
can happen
bottom close to out of time
um we've covered most of the major
things I wanted to get through the last
few slides are really just saying we had
to learn a lot of stuff we didn't really
know anything about DP
um most of our staff didn't know
anything about the Technologies spark
Roby Amazon web services that were sort
of critical to being able to work at the
scale we were working at and so there
was a lot of sort of like Auto didactic
self-teaching needed in order to make
any of this work
uh and then lastly um and this may be
familiar to folks it may not
um on a very practical note not sort of
the terms of Staffing I guess but if
there's a particular census product you
want to learn about there's almost
always a really lengthy like in the
central census case it's 700 or so pages
I think technical documentation document
you can look at and like without even
intending it as a joke this is actually
where I did most of my learning about
the 2020 and 2010 decennial censuses was
reading through this Tech document um it
actually was usually more informative
than a lot of the internal only
documents that were available to me that
being said there's also a lot of stuff
internal only that that you will not
find in this document but if you look at
a document like this usually you'll be
able to pick out things and say oh
that's that's a weird thing that clearly
is in conflict with the standard model
that we would assume in DP for trying to
handle tabulation production maybe I can
think of some way to like tweak that and
make it more DP friendly uh and lastly
if you uh
don't want to read the 700 page document
or you have other questions um that
you'd like to field you're welcome to
email me I would be happy to put you in
touch with my colleagues who also would
be most likely happy to talk to you as
well
um I won't know everything about most
census projects because there are
hundreds of them but usually we can take
it out to the right person is to talk to
um I also certainly won't know the right
way to talk about sort of Staffing
concerns but I know the managerial folks
who are involved in that um and they are
certainly interested in trying to to get
I think more involved with the DP
community
thank you
foreign
for one or two questions
um okay I I have six questions and I'm
not going to ask you all of them but I
am gonna just blurb them because it I
think it might be helpful to hear some
of the questions this raises for someone
who spent a lot of time thinking about
this
um one I was surprised to hear you talk
about the desire at The Bureau for
novelty that was really interesting when
you were like oh we were bummed that we
found this in a paper I would have
thought that would be really great and
so I'd love to talk to you more and
learn more about why novelty seems good
well let's talk about that you know two
the optimized units those those modified
block groups that you made that were
better aligned to municipalities
it would be great if You released those
more transparently uh three imputation
the way you impute missing information
it would be great if that was more
transparent I'm just telling you that
someone who's tried really hard to track
what you're doing these are places where
we lose the ability to track exactly
what's going on
um so if at least from where I say
imputation is very non-transparent how
that works
um there's been a lot of calls from the
community for you to release the noisy
file before post processing and it'd be
interesting to hear what you think about
that
um what's going on with the ACs like how
is all this gonna play out when you do
it on the ACs and is that still planned
for mid-decade and then finally do you
agree that there are way too many race
categories those are my six questions
maybe pick one
[Music]
well the easiest one is the novelty
question because I think that's mostly
my fault I was really the one who was
excited that it seemed like a novel
result
um but I mean in retrospect I actually
agree that it's probably better that it
was already published in the literature
so we could be confident that we hadn't
made a mistake in it
um
I'm trying to try to keep the full list
of six questions in my mind to figure
out okay
so uh the ACs question was the other one
that actually was stuck in my head that
I thought that I thought about going
back to um a primary problem with me
answering about ACS is that I don't work
on the project so I know the folks who
work on it I have conversations with
them about about where it's heading
um I don't think it is clear at this
point whether or not it will end up
being formally private but I wouldn't
necessarily quote me on that except to
ask someone else if I'm wrong
um
I I think folks have a lot to think
about given the kerfuffle that has
happened with the decennial census
um to make sure that they feel like uh
the way that modernization of ACS is
proceeding uh will be acceptable to
people
um it's possible as far as I'm aware
it's possible that maybe it could be the
ACs could end up with a non-formally
private system that is more modern and
expansive and less light touch probably
than the da systems of the past
um it's also potentially possible that
someone comes up with a really clever
way of handling it formally privately
and maybe the right managerial folks get
behind it and it ends up uh being
formally private but I really can't
indicate confidently either way
unfortunately
so I'd also like to know my guess is the
sort of way of saying that can I ask my
question or should should I do that
often
yeah we take it it'll be the last
question okay
um so one of the uh big uses of census
data is for redistricting
and I was wondering uh throughout your
talk that you know we're taking privacy
as sort of a given that we want to have
a differentially private data set but
what if a community decides that I don't
want my data to be differentially
private because it might impact uh my
political choices or impact in a
different way have have people thought
about that is is that
it's just
so I kind of wondered about this bit
myself
um
they're
title 13 is certainly not written with a
component that says you know go ask
folks whether or not they're they're
okay with this there are some cases in
which I've I've wondered a bit
um so with with uh Ain Homeland areas
with AA and governments there's kind of
government government relationship that
I frankly am not the expert on but I
have often wondered if you know if they
have different preferences about what
privacy accuracy trade-offs should be is
that a conversation that should be
opened up I mean should they should they
be able to say to dsap well we think we
shouldn't get the same privacy accuracy
trade off as another group of people I'm
ultimately not the person who should be
able to say whether whether that's the
case or not
um and it wasn't the choice that was
made the for this particular decadal
census but I think it's a good question
and I also
even even for for the none areas where
there's not that separate government
relationship
um I my personal opinion is that it
would be very helpful in making it more
understandable to decept
um and to helping them make decisions if
we had a general sense of what the
population at large thought of the
Privacy accuracy trade-off um that's a
big challenge in itself figuring out how
to formalize that and how to distill it
into something that would be
understandable uh but if we could have
statistics on folks from different
population groups saying hey like this
this is this is I mean they probably
wouldn't phrase it this way but this is
how I feel about the Privacy accuracy
trade-off curve um here's my primary
program parameterized form of it
um if we could take those and share them
with dsap and say hey this is what we've
got is feedback that might help them
think about
um what they think a reasonable
trade-off is uh although the only reason
I feel like that's a possibility that
they can that they may be able to think
about is because it's not like title 13
is even though it
doesn't admit this as a necessarily A
Criterion that should influence things
it's also it was written before DP
existed it was written before we had to
sort of uh but before the thinking about
the Continuum of trade-offs um sort of
became much clearer and so it doesn't
really tell you what the final Choice
should be so maybe there is some
opportunity for them to consider that
great uh let's thank Philip again
the lunch break now will be at back at
two o'clock for our next set of talks